it comes down to our fans too hard okay
you know listen Katy Perry's been
dealing with with stuff like that her
whole career it's wild this season of
American Idol idol is the best season I
just got the report from our our
showrunner that it's definitely the most
drama and you know Katie gets picked on
for
going out and trying to have fun making
a TV
[Applause]
showed yeah it's TV there's a little
dramatic that's one way to describe Katy
Perry's time on the latest season of
American Idol I'm just saying exactly
what the viewers are thinking we're
judging kids that people at home fall in
love with we're not going to bat a
thousand as judges now fellow judge Luke
Bryan is coming to her defense you can't
be so safe in the moment that you're so
homogenized well speaking to Fox news
about the Jabs Katie has endured over
the past year
[Music]
there was some boom and remember this
contestant it was embarrassing to have
that on TV and it was hurtful yeah it
cannot be 25. what are you saying yes
July I have three kids so that's like
yeah way from here what are you saying
okay Katie no it's okay if Katie lays on
the table I think I'm gonna pass three
kids honey you've been laying on the
table too much you know
I think that women supporting and
uplifting other women is so cool and I
think that mom changing is super lame it
even after landing a Golden Ticket Sarah
Beth said she'd had enough of Hollywood
what just happened is she gonna leave
what's happening I feel like I'm not
gonna hold on the show anyway so I might
as well I think we get set up
as judges you know we kind of fall on
the sword a lot of times and get set up
to where people
um Can can get very vocal on socials and
stuff we support them we nurture them we
give them constructive criticism and
they're really entering into a a
university and so we we just like teach
them everything we know in all of our
years my thing is I think when me and
Lionel and Katie sit down at the desk in
our hearts we're doing the best we can
sometimes you just gotta say stuff and
you know when you roll the dice on TV
like that it's just this thing's a wild
ride I've learned through the years that
you know
if you make a mistake publicly or
whatever your fans will have your back
here's the question fans are asking now
will Katie's critics cause her to leave
the show I
know tonight at dinner as long as the
vibe feels like we're over and upward
can we expect you back on the judges
panel next season if they want me back
I'm running through the door first thing
well we're working on it and it's been
an amazing year it's gonna be a tough
show for me and Lionel and Katie to walk
away from
foreign
[Music]